ja und wir alle warten auch wegen des
komplizierten reisens eigentlich auf
einen chor ohne impfstoff jetzt hat aber
der pharmakonzern astrazeneca die
klinischen studien für seinen krone
impfstoff vorsorglich gestoppt bei einem
teilnehmer sind gesundheitliche probleme
aufgetreten und dementsprechend hat man
das ganze gestoppt warum die die
erkrankung aussieht das hat das
britische unternehmen nicht mitgeteilt
dieses unternehmen arbeitet mit acht
weiteren pharma- und biotech-unternehmen
an einem ersten impfstoff und allerhand
versichert gestern erst dass man bei der
entwicklung des impfstoffes keine
kompromisse bei der sicherheit eingehen
möchte gott ist
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
für deutschland ja bereits 54 millionen
dosen des britischen impfstoffes
gesichert dr
thomas aßmann erst hausarzt und
internisten erstmal erklären sie uns das
doch bitte einmal so eine pausieren
bei der entwicklung eines impfstoffes
kommt das vor ist das normal oder zeigt
dass das vielleicht die unternehmen auf
dem falschen weg waren
nein eigentlich gar nicht erst mal grüß
gott nach berlin an sich ein gutes
zeichen weil wenn der pharmariese das
durchpeitschen wollte dann hätte er
vielleicht gar nicht informiert
also es ist gut dass so was aufgedeckt
wird
und wie gesagt bei einem fall bei 17.000
probanden das ist relativ niedrig das
wäre jetzt wenn man die musik durch
impfen wurde sammelt 50 millionen
impfdosen werden dass 3000 fälle
das ist natürlich immer noch zu hoch man
will den impfstoff natürlich noch
sicherer machen
deswegen wird jetzt geguckt hat patient
irgendwelche vorerkrankungen können
diese vorerkrankungen vielleicht das
ausgelöst haben oder liegt es wirklich
an in dem stoff ja mit seinem willen
impfstoff liegt kann man ihn doch
eigentlich verändern kann man da weiter
machen
also von daher ein gutes zeichen wenn
wir sehen der russische impfstoff
sputniks 05 oder v wir haben nur 100
probanden mit gemacht also ich würde er
dann dem stoff hat astrazeneca vertraut
ganz ehrlich gesagt gut nun beunruhigen
aber damit die meldung von einer
erkrankung wie schätzen sie das ein was
ist das wohl fühlen erkranken wie stark
muskel sein damit zumindest zeitweise
der prozess gestoppt wird
also man muss so sagen mit dem impfungen
damit der impfung überhaupt egal mit
welchem von greifen wir in das
immunologische system unseres körpers
ein
und der ist ja hoch komplex da dürfen
wir nicht vergessen zum beispiel vor 15
jahren in london sechs gesunde probanden
geimpft worden als vorstufe und alle
sechs sind schwerst erkrankt einer mit
bleibenden schäden vor und etwa zehn
jahren in rom auch bei einer ähnlichen
studie
dafür muss man sagen dass die schon im
tierversuch getestet worden sind zum
beispiel die probanden in london bekam 1
500 bild der dosierung die die affen
bekommen haben und trotzdem sind
schwerst erkrankt es ist immer ein
risiko und jetzt so viel ich diesem fall
jetzt kenne wurde gesagt dass der junge
mann aber diese person an einer
erkrankung des nervensystems an einer
entzündung anführungszeichen leidet
ähnlich zum beispiel eine bekannteste
entzündung das nervensystem ist ja auch
zb ein multiples große und das kann den
möglichen nebenwirkungen dieser impfung
sein weil dann vielleicht das
immunsystem so gelenkt worden ist dass
es selber diese nervenzellen angreift
aber das ist erst einmal nur spekulation
dann müssten jetzt noch nach forschung
gemacht wird ist das wirklich so
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren